uh well let's get reaction uh to today's
record-breaking temperature joining us
now tom heap presenter of our weekly
climate show here on sky news uh and he
can talk to us about the significance of
this record being broken today um tom
wish i was talking to you under better
circumstances this is certainly not
a record to celebrate but
describe to us the significance of what
we're witnessing and feeling today
it's nothing like i would have thought
i'd have seen in my lifetime really this
kind of temperature and i'm sitting in
in warwickshire in the middle of the
country and i can tell you my
thermometer here is it's
37.9 i don't know if you can see that so
by no means a national record but an
extraordinary temperature for this place
i do think we need to be a bit careful
uh in the media and in the wider sort of
community
it's easy to succumb to a bit of
recordism isn't it almost like we want
to get it higher we want to breach these
thresholds which is something we should
be so so
again really because it does mean
suffering for people and not just for
people this means suffering for for
nature as well which hasn't adapted in
this country to deal with these kind of
temperatures and also our farmland both
in terms of livestock and crops a short
blip um
perhaps plants can deal with but longer
than that
these kind of trends spell real danger
for both our livestock and our crops in
this country so just a massive change
and i mean yes this is a blip but it's a
blip on an upward trend
tom we've spoken about this over the
last 24 hours that this
could be the new norm from a lot of
experts i've spoken to they knew this
was going to happen they perhaps didn't
think or hoped that it wouldn't happen
as quickly as this
what's going to be the pattern going
forward as you said more blips more
frequently
i i think that's what all the climate
scientists are saying uh you know more
blips on the increasingly rising trend
so what's exceptional now might be much
more normal by 2030. i think the other
thing we need to look at is what's being
called adaptation how do we uh react to
this i mean your correspondent who is at
king's cross was talking about people
wanting the the train network adapted to
this it's quite a subtle debate now
because we need to be a little bit
careful about adapting to something that
happens rarely because all these things
cost money so yeah you know you could
make your railway network you know 45
degree proof but how often is it going
to happen we have the same thing in
winter certainly in the past we did when
people were saying you know how come we
don't have the investment in gritters
and snow plows to clean our roads the
answer is because it doesn't happen very
often so that adaptation piece is quite
complicated and i think the other thing
to be wearing a lot of people have been
talking about air conditioning
i have pretty strong views for air
conditioning you know installing air
conditioning in my view is a bit like
buying a fridge and hiding in it while
your house is burning down around
the problem with air conditioning is not
only is it fixing not fixing the problem
it also uses a lot of energy around the
world
more energy is used for air conditioning
for cooling than it is for heating
so cooling us is driving global warming
and we have to be very careful about
thinking about air conditioning i think
we need much more many more passive
things the way that our houses are built
simple things like awnings or windows
can make a lot of difference and also
maybe some of us
accept occasional discomfort you know
sweating isn't necessarily a bad thing
you know it's a very effective natural
process
we're not diminishing the real health
threat there is to those who are elderly
or infirm or if this goes on for a long
time but i think we need to be careful
about some of the knee-jerk adaptation
no i get your point um i was having
quite a heated exchange with someone
this morning who said that they were
desperately trying to find an air
conditioning unit and i said but the
temperature is going to drop on
wednesday just ride it out and do the
best you can anyway we we agreed to
differ on that point but tom i know you
like to be optimistic i know you like to
be optimistic
i know you like to be optimistic so i i
want to end
on an optimistic note because it's not
too late is it we can change course and
i know there's always so much emphasis
on what the individual can do how we can
change our recycling habits not by air
conditioning units but there are bigger
things that can be done i'm talking
about government big business it's not
too late to stop what's happening to the
uk and and the globe right now
we basically know what we need to do
which is vastly reduce our
economy and society's dependence on
burning stuff particularly fossil fuels
and there are so many ways to do that
now in terms of low carbon energy i
don't if you can see it might be too
bright like there's some solar panels on
a roof over here i'm not sure
but you know and
and appetite for those is growing hugely
at the moment especially when fossil
fuels are so expensive installers are
those who run off their feet this isn't
something we can just do domestically
this is something we are doing and we
can do a lot more nationally and
internationally and it is so important
that we do not lose sight
of these
ambitions and these goals because you
know we've seen this year if you like a
lot more uh pointed
uh immediate acute threats
be they pandemics you know the war in
ukraine but i'm if there's one tiny good
thing that could come out of this
terrible heat wave is that it reminds
people that climate change is an acute
threat and it deserves to be
maintained at the very very top
tom really good to talk to you as i said
where she was under better circumstances
is not a record we wanted to be marking
today but the uk marking is hot as ever
temperature tom heap presenter of our
weekly climate show thank you so much
for joining us this afternoon thank you